[Music]
on this friday night the fatal weight in
uvalde
the wrong decision period there's no no
excuse for that why desperate calls from
inside the classroom went unanswered
we're not giving up our guns while
protesters demanding action on gun
reform confront the nra
canadian killers get mercy from the
courts the supreme court ruling offering
hope of release and how victim families
are reacting
shocking conditions for vulnerable youth
so this is my prison
an investigation of ontario's child
welfare system reveals major failure
and an epic musical reunion
after more than four decades apart abba
returns to the stage with a digital
twist
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight chris galas
good evening and thanks for joining us
uvalde police now admit wrong decisions
were made while kids were being gunned
down inside an elementary school the 19
children and two teachers who were
killed
should have been celebrating their first
day of summer vacation today instead
their families are planning funerals the
gunman that stormed into robb elementary
on tuesday barricaded himself inside a
classroom full of children for nearly an
hour many students were calling 9-1-1
while more than a dozen officers stood
outside waiting for reinforcements
19 like i said there was 19 officers in
there in fact there was plenty of
officers to do whatever needed to be
done on retrospect from where i'm
sitting right now clearly there was kids
in the room
jackson proskow joins us from uvalde
tonight and jackson texas police are
supposed to be trained in active shooter
situations so what happened here
well chris active shooter training means
that police are supposed to keep firing
on a suspect until the suspect is no
longer a threat clearly that did not
happen here all because of a simple
mistake a belief that anyone inside the
school was already dead
each new revelation makes the pain more
unbearable as this shattered town learns
some of the 21 victims from robb
elementary died as police stood by and
refused to enter the classroom where
they were ambushed of course it was not
the right decision it was a wrong
decision period there's no no excuse for
that state investigators now believe the
school district's chief of police made a
fatal error in judgment deciding not to
breach the classroom door even as
children inside called 9-1-1 begging for
help the on-scene commander
considered a barricaded subject and that
there was time and there were no more
children at risk
obviously
obviously you know based upon the
information we have there were children
in that classroom that were at risk and
it was in fact still an active shooter
situation investigators can't explain
why the school's armed resource officer
wasn't there
they admit a teacher left a door to the
outside propped open allowing the gunman
access to the school as children
repeatedly begged
please send police now
19 officers stood in the hallway outside
the classroom
19 children would later be pronounced
dead
all while their parents were held back
by police outside the school pleading to
be let in to rescue their children
you know forget how i'm doing what about
the parents
of those children
don't forget about me what about be
our officers and stuff like that we take
an oath to uphold the law and protect
people
in yuvaldi's historic town square
there's a growing memorial and a growing
sense of disbelief and outrage all those
kids that have crosses there those are
all my friends they
they all died and
i just feel really bad because
my friend you know it might it broke my
heart into a million pieces
nine-year-old angela left school early
that day just moments before the
shooting her mother can't understand why
police didn't break down the classroom
door i think they should have acted
faster the faster the better because an
hour was enough to kill a lot of kids
by this seed i have no words because i
don't know what he was thinking said the
mother of the 18 year old gunman
i just want the innocent children who
died to forgive me survivors too have
been robbed of so much life
gripped by nightmares and sadness angela
says she's not sure if she can ever
return to the place that took her
friends i feel uh nervous now because
since it all happened i think it's going
to happen again and
i don't know i don't want to go i'm
scared
supporting survivors and victims
families is going to be a long and
ongoing process the state is working to
cover travel costs and counseling costs
and local funeral homes say that the
cost of any funerals for the victims
will be completely covered
chris
all right jackson accountability might
help in this case given what we learned
about police action and inaction today
what are texas officials doing to find
out what went wrong and make sure it
doesn't happen again
well after initially praising the police
response the governor of texas now says
he was completely misled the deepest
calls though for some sort of formal
investigation to police actions are
actually coming from washington where
members of congress are calling on both
the fbi and the department of justice to
probe exactly what happened and what
went so terribly wrong
all right we'll see where it leads
that's jackson proskow in uvalde tonight
thank you jackson
a five-hour drive from uvalde in houston
the national rifle association is
holding its national convention despite
calls for it to be canceled or postponed
tens of thousands of gun advocates are
there and so is heather yorick's west
for our coverage tonight heather
an emotional group of people gathered in
protest as the national rifle
association opened its weekend
convention here in downtown houston the
national lobby group has not had a
gathering this size since before the
pandemic but just days after a gunman
took the lives of 19 children the anger
here is clear
in the center of america's fourth
largest city the divide at the center of
american life is laid bare i'm concerned
about kids i have a fourth grader i have
a second grader and it's just
trying to explain that or imagining
these people's pain across the street 14
acres of guns gear and paraphernalia the
nra's annual gathering just days after
uvalde a city park full of protesters
made their frustration clear i'm a
christian
and uh as far as i know what i see in
scripture tells me that i need to care
about these children's lives and no more
children should be taken like this but
on the other side of a police barricade
thousands of card carrying members of
the nra congregation seem to pay little
attention to the crowds with the
socialists trying to take over our
country
we're not giving up our guns some of the
weekend's musical acts including don
mclean canceled performances bad
business perhaps but most of the
weekend's events are proceeding this
show will go on people want to protest
it's their right to protest but i'm here
to support
nra our gun rights and
to protect my family my friends texas
governor greg abbott was one of the
headliners he canceled his appearance
late thursday opting to appear only by
video
donald trump will be here though
renewing his support for american gun
laws in an interview with the salem news
channel you have to give that second
amendment great protection
because without it
we would be
a very
dangerous country frankly ironically
secret service protocols around the
former president mean no firearms are
allowed in the nra crowd here making
this one of the only places in texas
guns are banned the city's mayor said he
didn't have the power to cancel this
weekend's convention but they did ramp
up security significantly local state
and federal resources are here to help
keep all of those emotions from erupting
into violence chris
heather yorks west in houston for us
tonight thank you heather
the 19 children killed in uvalde were
top of mind for families of buffalo
grocery store shooting victims calling
for change as they lay their loved ones
to rest
before we could finish the funerals in
buffalo
[Music]
you got 19
shot and killed with the same kind of
weapons
in texas
[Music]
and unless we start dealing with these
easy access to guns
all of us are talking
funerals for three of the ten buffalo
victims were held today
back in this country now the supreme
court of canada struck down the
punishment of life in prison without
parole for mass murderers today the
ruling came during a review of the case
of alexander bissonnette found guilty of
killing six worshipers at a quebec
mosque in 2017. tonight abigail beeman
tells us why the court finds his
punishment unconstitutional
as worshipers gathered at this quebec
city mosque for evening prayer in 2017
alexandre bissonette opened fire killing
six people and wounding five more now he
will have a chance at parole after 25
years the muslim community he attacked
calls that a disappointment a deep
concern it's about the orphans
that will see the
the murder
the
murdering person
in the road of quebec city 25 years
after after this tragedy a fear for
victims though the supreme court
declaring parole eligibility after 50
years unconstitutional only guarantees
inmates the ability to apply
granting parole is up to the parole
board the likelihood
of such a person getting parole at 25
years is extremely rare the court's
unanimous decision raises concerns about
prisoners with no realistic chance of
parole before they die calling such
sentences incompatible with human
dignity denying offenders any
possibility of reintegration into
society a sentence so absurd that it
would bring the administration of
justice into disrepute it strikes down a
2011 criminal code provision that
allowed for longer periods the supreme
court
decision made clear that this
provision of the criminal code was cruel
and unusual
and inherently so it's not about them
it's really about us and who we are we
abolish the death penalty we abolish
corporal punishment there are few
affected cases in canada justin burks is
one sentenced to a historic 75 years
before a chance of parole after killing
three mounties in 2014. i've been doing
this for 45 years
and i cannot remember another decision
that was this retroactive sentencing can
now move ahead for alek minassian
convicted of murdering 10 people in the
2018 toronto van attack ontario superior
court waiting on this legal benchmark
first
abigail beeman global news ottawa
just ahead shedding light on a broken
system what a global news investigation
reveals about living conditions for some
of ontario's most vulnerable youth
a year-long investigation by global news
and aptn examining the state of the
child welfare system in ontario has
uncovered some deeply disturbing
conditions for some of the province's
most vulnerable youth children going
hungry and repeatedly physically
restrained by staff as carolyn jarvis
reports the province promises to
overhaul the system but some wonder if
it'll go far enough
jessica fowler was bounced through
foster care and group homes 15 times i
had to go through this just because like
i didn't have parents it's not normal
yeah it's just not normal
the most violent she says was a group
home she arrived at in 2017
where she says she was repeatedly
physically restrained for things as
simple as making toast at the wrong time
they want to put me in this like
restraint and they pushed my face into
like my mattress and i couldn't breathe
at all like i was trying to like scream
and i couldn't say anything
using the freedom of information law
global news and aptn were able to
uncover which group homes and foster
care homes are submitting the most
serious occurrence reports in ontario
reports which include deaths injuries
missing kids
and restraints
restraints are permitted by the
government only when children pose an
immediate risk to themselves or others
so this is my prison the home jessica
went to was run by a company called mary
homes which today operates five group
homes in the ottawa area it was pretty
scary delana land was there at the same
time two thousand kilometers from her
first nation in northern ontario there
was nails in the windows because we
weren't allowed to leave the rooms
mary holmes which declined our request
for an interview had the third highest
number of serious occurrence reports per
bed in the province we have a whole
group of kids
who may or may not
be safe experts say the volume of
serious occurrence reports may be an
indication that staff lack basic
training we have frontline workers where
the minimum qualification is that they
have a driver's license and perhaps a
high school diploma starting next summer
the province will require frontline
workers have a post-secondary education
or experience deemed relevant
but it stops short of requiring that
training be specifically in child and
youth care it's a system that doesn't
really focus on the dignity and the care
and the well-being of young people the
ontario government says it's undertaking
a redesign of its child welfare system a
promise that's been made many times
before it breaks my heart that my bed
was basically replaced with another kid
who's in the same situation
that i was in
carolyn jarvis global news toronto
and you can watch global's expanded
coverage of our investigation into
ontario's child welfare system on the
new reality saturday at 8 pm
just ahead a residential school survivor
opens up for the first time about the
abuse that nearly broke her and how she
recovered
[Music]
exactly one year ago today the world
learned 215 suspected unmarked graves
believed to be mostly children had been
found on the grounds of the former
kamloops indian residential school that
announcement sparked a national
reckoning about the residential school
system in canada but for survivors it
meant reawakening trauma tonight one of
those survivors is sharing details of
her story even members of her family
haven't heard nitu garcia reports
shirley paul says attending the memorial
marking a year since the detection of
unmarked graves on these grounds helped
her heal
she hugged the prime minister
and in the days since now back in her bc
home about an hour and a half away she's
opening up about the darkest chapters of
her life for the first time
i kept it hidden
inside of me
i didn't want to talk about it
shirley says it felt like an eternity
but she remembers spending at least five
years in the former kamloops indian
residential school in the early 1950s
when we got there
first thing they did
the sisters did
was take all your clothes off and stick
you on the double i swear they put me in
the bleach because that water burnt
she says she didn't know what starvation
was until she came here and you're so
hungry
already eating potato peeling and we got
caught the sister came in
and took us out of there and we got a
scrapping
when i got sick
they put me
to bed
and they didn't feed me
punishment carried out by teachers and
nuns was relentless
and you get a that is dropping
you're not allowed
to speak your language
tried to beat the language out of us
it's definitely an eye-opener
you know i've i haven't heard the
stories come forth from her
i just can't believe that
she showed us love
and cared for us when she never had it
and
that makes her one of the most strongest
people i know
shirley went on to become a teacher
herself developing and implementing a
program focused on her traditional
okanagan language that was the most
happiest moment of my life to have the
certificate
finally breaking her silence showing how
the institution failed to break her
nitu garcia global news silk okanagan
territory
and a reminder there is support
available for survivors of residential
schools and their families the number is
toll-free 24 hours a day it's 1-800-721
music from the past in a performance
that seems like it's from the future
swedish super group abba beaming back on
a new digital stage
[Music]
thousands of abba fans are buzzing after
watching the swedish super group perform
some of its biggest hits looking exactly
like it did when they split up 40 years
ago crystal gomezing shows us why this
was no ordinary concert with the band
beaming itself back to life
[Applause]
the music
the makeup
the mood
abba is back
having called on the world to again take
a chance on them abba kicked off a world
first concert going experience in london
absolutely fantastic
if i died tonight i'd die happy
brilliant it was unbelievable it was
extraordinary the arena here in east
london was specially created for abba
voyage it's an immersive experience with
seating around a dance floor huge
screens and a live band and the avatars
unlike this rudimentary likeness we
whipped up were painstakingly created
over years
[Music]
we spent five and a half years in this
and we're all in our 70s i don't think
we'll do another one so no more to come
i think not i'd say i say definitely no
but never say never but it's a no people
have a second life
yeah
the avatars go on living you know
the avatars portray the band members in
their youthful primes the real group
performed over five weeks wearing motion
capture suits at times younger dancers
were brought in to pull off some of the
moves but the result
a concert like no other oh my goodness
it was so good it was like i was beamed
up in a spaceship branded by abba i
danced i jived i had the time of my life
it was like it ticked all the boxes
speaking of boxes much like ikea
furniture abba voyage can be packed and
reassembled anywhere in the world
maybe it's a swedish thing crystal
gomencing global news
london
and that is global national for this
friday night i am the real chris galas
tonight's your canada is the fog rolling
into the harbor in st john's
newfoundland thanks very much for
watching we'll hope to see you again
here tomorrow have a great weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]